♪ ♪
>> Tucker: FOR THE TIME BEING,
THE BIGGEST THREAT TO YOUR
SECOND AMENDMENT RIGHTS
GUARANTEED TO YOUR ANCESTORS
OVER 200 YEARS AGO ISN'T
ACTUALLY LAWMAKERS OR KIDS FROM
PARKLAND YOU SEE ON CABLE
TELEVISION.
IT COULD BE BIG CORPORATIONS.
LAST MONTH, CITIGROUP DEMANDED
ALL ITS BUSINESS PARTNERS
RESTRICT GUN SALES.
A LETTER WAS JUST SENT TO
WELLS FARGO, BANK OF AMERICA,
AND VISAS SAYING THEY OUGHT TO
EXPLORE THE POSSIBILITY OF
BLOCKING CREDIT CARD USERS FROM
BUYING GUNS, AMMUNITIONS, OR
FIREARMS RELATED ACCESSORIES.
SOME TOWNS ARE ACTING AS WELL.
DEERFIELD ILLINOIS HAS JUST
PASSED A BAN ON SO-CALLED
ASSAULT WEAPONS.
ANY PERSON IN THE TOWN IS
REQUIRED TO GIVE THEM UP AND
THOSE WHO DON'T WILL BE FINED
$1,000 A DAY.
MARK STEYN IS AN AUTHOR AND
COLUMNIST AND JOINS US TONIGHT.
BOTH OF THESE STORIES --
DEERFIELD HAS BANNED THE
PURCHASE OF WEAPONS THAT ARE
HELD BY LAW-ABIDING PEOPLE.
HE WOULD HAVE TO GO DOOR TO
DOOR, WOULDN'T YOU?
>> I THINK YOU DO.
I WOULD BE SURPRISED, EVEN IN
THE MOST LIBERAL JURISDICTION IF
YOU CAN MAKE THE CASE THAT
$1,000 A DAY BEARS ANY RELATION
TO THE OFFENSE.
I DON'T THINK THAT WILL STAND UP
IN ANYBODY'S MIND TO CONTEST
THAT FINE.
I WOULD ADVISE PEOPLE TO
CONTESTED BECAUSE I THINK THAT
IS ABSOLUTELY OUTRAGEOUS AND
IT'S INTENDED BASICALLY TO
INTIMIDATE PEOPLE INTO GIVING UP
SOMETHING WHICH THE DAY BEFORE
YESTERDAY WAS ENTIRELY LAWFUL
FOR THEM TO HAVE.
>> Tucker: ULTIMATELY, ALL OF
THESE CONVERSATIONS COME DOWN TO
FOREST.
YOU'LL HAVE TO START MAKING
PEOPLE DO THINGS COME OUT
LAW-ABIDING PEOPLE, AMERICAN
CITIZENS DO SOMETHING THEY DON'T
WANT TO DO.
THE PRESSURE TO CONTROL SEEMS TO
BE COMING FROM CORPORATE AMERICA
WHICH IS HARD FOR SOME
CONSERVATIVES TO GET THEIR HEADS
AROUND BECAUSE THEY THINK WE ARE
ON EACH OTHER'S SIDE.
THINGS HAVE CHANGED IT SEEMS
LIKE.
>> THAT'S WHAT'S INTERESTING
ABOUT THE NEW YORK PROPOSAL.
IF YOU WANT TO GET RID OF GUNS,
IF YOU WANT TO CURTAIL ACCESS TO
GUNS, DO YOU DO AS JOHN PAUL
STEVENS, THE FORMER
SUPREME COURT HONCHO SUGGESTS AN
REPEAL OF SECOND AMENDMENT?
THAT'S NEVER GOING TO HAPPEN.
INSTEAD, YOU GET CORPORATIONS
AND LEAN ON THEM TO DO IT AROUND
TO THE CONSTITUTION.
IF YOU LOOK AT WHAT'S HAPPENED
WITH THE WAY CORPORATIONS WHO
ARE QUITE HAPPY TO RESTRICT
FREEDOM OF EXPRESSION, WE'VE
SEEN OVER THE LAST YEAR, PAYPAL
AND OTHER MERCHANT PROCESSORS
ARE QUITE HAPPY TO ELIMINATE
CUSTOMERS ON IDEOLOGICAL
GROUNDS.
AT THE MOMENT, IT'S TECHNICALLY
DIFFICULT.
IF YOU GO INTO WALMART AND USER
A MASTERCARD, THEY CAN'T
TECHNICALLY TELL WHETHER YOU'RE
BUYING A COUPLE OF TWINKIES AND
A BLUEBERRY MUFFIN OR A FIREARM.
ONCE THEY CAN GET PAST THAT
HURDLE, A BELL GOES OFF AND YOUR
NORMAL CREDIT CARD WON'T WORK
WHEN YOU BUY A FIREARM, THEY
WILL HAVE GONE A LONG WAY TO DO
YOU NORMALIZE GUN SECOND
AMENDMENT RIGHTS AND THAT'S WHY
WHEN THEY PROPOSE THIS STUFF AND
PEOPLE THINK IT'S CRAZY, YOU
SHOULD ALWAYS LISTEN VERY
CAREFULLY TO WHAT THE LEFT IS
TELLING YOU BECAUSE THEY MEAN
IT.
>> Tucker: EXACTLY.
I SPENT 48 YEARS NOT BECOMING A
CONSPIRACY MINDED NOT, A TINFOIL
HAT GUY, BUT I HAVE TO SAY I
NOTICED THE SAME PEOPLE WHO ARE
PUSHING FOR SOCIAL CONTROL USING
FINANCIAL INSTRUMENTS LIKE
CREDIT CARDS ARE THE SAME ONES
CALLING FOR A CASHLESS SOCIETY
AND YOU'LL BE DEPENDENT UPON
CREDIT CARDS.
>> CHECKS ARE ALL BUT USELESS
AND SO EFFECTIVELY, THEY WILL BE
SAYING WHETHER YOU CAN HAVE A
MASTERCARD OR VISA CARD.
EITHER WAY, YOU CAN'T BUY A GUN
WITH IT.
THAT'S INTENTIONAL.
THESE THINGS ARE NOT ACCIDENTAL.
>> Tucker: MARK STEYN WILL
JOIN US IN A COUPLE OF SEGMENTS
BECAUSE HILLARY CLINTON HAS
CLAIMED THAT SHE IS THE CHAMPION